[Musique]
ses portes sont enfin ouvertes il n'a
pas fallu moins de 22 mois pour que
l'église de voisins-le-bretonneux
retrouve une deuxième jeunesse 22 mois
de restauration c'est une épreuve pour
une paroisse ces 22 mois de dispersion
ses 22 mois sans trop savoir où se
réunir donc on était content que ces 22
mois se termine des travaux plus long
que prévu l'avancée des travaux a été
interrompu pour relancer des études
concernant la densité du sol un sol qui
a finalement été refait avec 30 de
micropieux pour pouvoir porter la dalle
cent mille euros se sont ajoutés aux 350
me prévus au départ un investissement
pour un you for patrimoine elle va avoir
cinq cents ans bientôt elle a eu
plusieurs vies
ça a d'abord été un lieu de culte et une
église a ensuite été un temple de la
pensée pendant la révolution française
ensuite elle a été partiellement
détruite pendant la guerre de 39-45 et
en partie reconstruite
pourquoi là il ya une vraie double
vocation à la fois dans la location et
vente cultuelle est à la fois la
vocation de patrimoine du sol au plafond
tout a été restauré
sans oublier les vitraux et le tableau
de sainte geneviève
l'une des trois seules représentations
de la sainte en france nos églises est
formidable elle était belle à ben bella
encore plus belle maintenant j'étais
déjà très beau avant parce que dix très
ancienne qui retrouve une seconde
jeunesse sur tout ça très intéressant
est magnifique
fier de son église toute neuve la
paroisse dessert désormais s'ouvrir à un
public plus large avec notamment des
concerts tous les dimanches après midi
[Musique]